[Music]  Alfonzo karate you girls been very busy  irony Ruby  mrs. Brennan I won't bite Claire you're  the one I have to watch out for aren't  you  listen my husband's at 24 more months  left out her services you girls are  gonna be just fully we're gonna take  care of you I can't even make the rip  what they gave me last night  what are we gonna do all these men  working these streets and not a solid  set of balls in here bunch of guys that  don't even remember what family means so  we remind them I don't want you to  I want you to teach me  step off my business  baby it's my business man and if you  need to talk to [ __ ] through then get  out of our way I know their rights to  wipe you off the face of the earth  we worked hard for this you want to go  back to how it was  I rather died and go back  you go to war there's no coming back  Claire put a bullet in his head you  girls kill me  [Music]  [Music]